Paula Abdul forever your girl residency
congratulations thank you so much on a
scale of 1 to 10 how nerve-wracking is
it for you to be jumping off something
that I heard was 15 feet to do a swan
dive what can you tell us well it's it's
nerve-racking just I always get those
butterflies and nerves before performing
period
yeah but jumping off tall buildings and
things like that I love doing that you
do know I do I when I performed it the
Billboard Music Awards I wanted to show
a little taste of what my residency the
under type of energy my residency is
about so yeah I get jumping off of a
tall platform out of the way during the
first number you are an iconic dancer
and performer and I know this show you
give a hundred and ten percent
what kind of bruises do you get after
the show I wish I could show you because
it looks really bad really bruises all
over my legs my rib cage I'd like you
can see the fingerprint bruises of
people grabbing my because I'm being
lifted and thrown all over the place
yes but yeah they're big bruises yeah
when you get home I hear that you do ice
baths is that what you're did I put my
body in ice just to get the inflammation
down it's grueling it's not comfortable
no but it's necessary as a dancer I
understand that you are allergic to
twerking that's my favorite dance move I
am allergic to twerking it's just the
one dance move there I just don't like
doing yeah so you you can do it I I
don't pride myself on being the best
twerker I can do it but I don't feel
good doing it yeah so at the club this
is not something we're gonna see from
you know I've never been one to bend
over
you know you know it's little 30 years
since the release of this do you have
any advice for your younger self oh my
goodness I think that wisdom and
experience that I've gained taught me to
not take things so seriously and try to
be present the gift of being able to
still do what I love to do is is
incredible and I'm I don't take that
lightly I'm very grateful for it and if
I you know when I want to speak to my
younger self I always say you know live
life to the fullest and don't be afraid
to say no there's reasons for that
because something graders didn't come
along and try to find balance
with the rollercoaster of life there's
been a lot of highs and lows would you
say there is a mantra that you live by
every single day just like your go-to
thing you know I meditate every day it's
important for me to take some time to
myself
and just get my breathing you know be
conscious of my breathing and and to try
to let things that are causing me any
stress or anxiety to just kind of wither
away and and be present you know there's
nothing that I can control other than
showing up on stage and doing the best
that I can and the rest of it it's you
know it's I throw caution to the wind
yeah because there's something
exhilarating about having that freedom
to just let it go and for me if I mess
up no one no one's gonna know and it's
my own personal oh crap I messed up but
sometimes with those mess ups come a new
freedom of performing so your residency
is in Las Vegas are you a gambler what
do you do on your days off okay I'm not
a gambler but I do bet on myself
I like back yeah no but I am very lucky
at the tables if I walked by a night and
I just play because I'm the same just
come play a hand I've been known to win
some money
Oh poker blackjack blackjack that's my
game I played keno and won I've done the
slot machines in one yeah but I don't
make a habit of it yeah will we see you
go to maybe Magic Mike oh gosh
every day I have off I'm gonna go see a
new show I hear Magic Mike is incredible
so yeah I'm looking
yeah your music has been the soundtrack
just so many of our lives who has been
the soundtrack to your life well you
know I have a sister Wendy who's 7 years
older than I am so I grew up listening
to her taste in music and I'm very
grateful because she had great taste so
I grew up worshiping Stevie Wonder and
and the Jacksons and Earth Wind and Fire
and Joni Mitchell and you know I when
I'm in my dressing room getting ready I
have a playlist of really fun happy
songs get me in the mood it just man
feel good and Stevie Wonder's a big part
of it
yeah you have a collection of hits that
you perform at your residency is there
any song in particular that you are
either tired of singing or surprised by
how successful it was
I don't I'm not tired of singing songs I
mean sometimes I'm tired of doing the
production aspect of it because it's
it's not an easy show full of energy is
but I just love looking out and into the
showroom and seeing everyone sing along
that's what really makes me smile is
that everyone knows every word to all of
my song all of them yeah yeah is there
anybody that will either maybe grace the
stage or anyone that you've invited any
one of your friends that you're hoping
will see this show
well since it's the grand opening I'm
hoping that a lot of people get to come
see it I know that they're planning to
I'm here through January so yeah yeah I
know any famous friends I know you've
got a lot girl who's coming to the show
famous people coming but they're coming
on they're coming on different days yeah
when their schedule permits
you